i want to wish you a very merry
christmas
christmas is a time for christians
across britain and across the world
to celebrate the birth of jesus christ
it's a time to come together to spend
time with friends with family and with
loved ones christmas is also a time of
reflection
this year like last year has been
incredibly difficult for our country
too many families have experienced
unimaginable loss
for too many there'll be one less chair
at the table for the christmas meal
but in the darkest of times christian
values of kindness of compassion and
hope have shone through
communities have come together to help
one another
key workers have saved countless lives
armed service men and women
both here and abroad have as ever
played a huge part in protecting us all
our brilliant nhs which has done so much
good since labor founded it almost 75
years ago now has vaccinated the country
you keep our country safe
on behalf of all of us
i want to say a heartfelt
thank you
this year has been tough
but i believe that if we stick together
support each other and work together we
can find a path through i know a better
future is possible
so from my family to yours
i wish you all
a very merry christmas